ahora que tenemos la fórmula de la
distancia como una función del ángulo
theta que es el ángulo al que estamos
lanzando el objeto ahora usaremos un
poco de cálculo para encontrar el ángulo
óptimo de lanzamiento para optimizar la
distancia y como solo nos interesan
ángulos que estén en el rango de 0 a 90
grados lo anotamos acá esto nos va a
ayudar con las restricciones para
optimizar nuestro ángulo que esté en 30
grados y 90 grados
veamos cómo podemos resolver esto y para
tener una idea de lo que queremos
conceptualmente analizar utilizando el
cálculo recordemos que al hacer una
derivada vamos a encontrar la pendiente
de una línea o de una curva y si
fuéramos a graficar esto y de hecho los
invito para que lo hagan de preferencia
con una calculadora gráfica esta gráfica
se vería algo así tenemos aquí nuestro
eje de la derivada de theta y aquí abajo
tendríamos nuestro eje del ángulo theta
y este ángulo va de 0 a 90 grados como
ya habíamos visto aquí están cero grados
y aquí están 90 grados
de esta función se verá así más o menos
y lo que queremos hacer es encontrar el
ángulo que estará más o menos por acá
que nos dará la distancia óptima esto de
aquí es la distancia óptima y lo que
queremos hacer es encontrar justamente
esto y lo que observamos en esta gráfica
que ustedes también podrían observar si
tienen su calculadora gráfica es que en
este punto de acá la pendiente justo en
ese punto va a estar totalmente
horizontal es decir esta pendiente será
igual a cero así que lo que tenemos que
hacer es encontrar la derivada de esta
ecuación es encontrar la derivada de
esta función y después encontrar con
cuál ángulo esta derivada es igual a
cero o la pendiente instantánea de esta
función es igual a cero y con eso ya
terminaríamos conoceremos cuál es el
ángulo óptimo del lanzamiento de nuestro
proyectil encontremos la derivada aquí
vamos a usar nuestras reglas de las
derivadas de prima de teta o la derivada
de la distancia como función de theta es
igual a suponemos que 2 por s al
cuadrado entre g es una constante así
que
vamos a poner tal cual aquí en nuestra
derivada no se va a afectar y ahora
emplearemos la regla del producto de las
derivadas con respecto a theta la regla
del producto nos dice que tomamos la
derivada del primer factor y lo
multiplicamos por el segundo factor así
que la derivada de coseno detecta es
menos se lo detecta y lo multiplicamos
por seno de teta a esto le sumamos el
primer factor por la derivada del
segundo factor en este caso el primer
factor es coseno de teta por la derivada
del segundo factor que es coseno de teta
así que nos queda coseno de teta paul
coseno de teta y para que esto quede
claro y no nos compliquemos vamos a
indicar que la derivada del coche no de
teta corresponde a este menos seno de
teta y la derivada del seno de teta
corresponde a este coche no detecta de
aquí abajo y ahora simplificamos de
prima de teta es igual a 2s cuadrada
entre g por menos seno de teta porsche
no detecta es igual a menos seno
cuadrado
detecta más cosas no detecta por coche
no detecta coseno cuadrado de teta y
ahora queremos encontrar el ángulo en el
cual la pendiente instantánea de esta
curva sea igual a cero así que pongamos
todo esto igual a cero
y ahora tenemos que encontrar teta y lo
primero que voy a hacer para despejar
teta es dividir ambos lados de esta
ecuación entre 2 s cuadrada entre g si
dividimos el lado izquierdo entre esto
nos va a quedar que se cancela este 2
por s cuadrada entre g y si dividimos 0
entre 12 se cuadrada entre g suponiendo
que esto no es 0 que no debería hacerlo
pues seguiremos teniendo ser así que
esta ecuación se simplifica como menos
seno cuadrado detectan más coseno
cuadrado de teta igual a 0
y ahora lo que voy a hacer es sumar seno
cuadrado de tete en ambos lados de esta
ecuación así que lo escribo aquí más
seno cuadrado detecta estos dos senos se
cancelan y me queda como resultado
coseno cuadrado de teta igual a seno
cuadrado de teta ahora estos dos van a
ser positivos en el intervalo de ángulos
que hemos especificado así que no
tenemos ningún problema si dividimos
ambos lados de esta ecuación entre
coseno cuadrado detecta esto entre
coseno cuadrado detecta y esta forma es
interesante ya que el lado izquierdo se
cancela y nos queda uno y este uno va a
ser igual a bueno cuánto es seno
cuadrado detecta / coseno cuadrado de
teta va a ser lo mismo que tener seno
detecta / jose no detecta todo esto
elevado al cuadrado tenemos algo al
cuadrado que divide otra cosa al
cuadrado es lo mismo que tener el
numerador dividido entre el denominador
y el resultado elevado al cuadrado y qué
seno de teta / coseno de teta pues eso
va a ser la tangente de teta así que
tenemos que uno es igual a la tangente
cuadrada de teta y si tomamos la raíz
positiva de la raíz cuadrada en ambos
lados de esta ecuación
recordamos que la tangente es positiva
en este intervalo de teta que va de 0 a
90 grados
así que si tomamos la raíz cuadrada
positiva en ambos lados nos va a quedar
que raíz cuadrada de 1 es uno raíz
cuadrada de tangente al cuadrado es
igual a tangente de teta y ahora
aplicamos la tangente inversa en ambos
lados de la igualdad o el arco tangente
lo que nos dan arco tangente de 1 va a
ser igual a teta y esa es una manera
sofisticada de decir que te caes el
ángulo al cual al tomarle su tangente
nos va a dar 1 y pueden usar una
calculadora para encontrar esto o
también lo pueden memorizar el arco
tangente de 1 es igual a 45 grados así
que esta teta es igual a 45 grados o si
lo quieren saber en radiales va a ser
entre
radiales y cualquiera de estos dos les
va a funcionar así que el ángulo óptimo
cuando arrojamos este objeto va a ser de
45 grados y bueno cuál será la distancia
óptima si es que usamos este ángulo de
45 grados si lo estamos arrojando a 45
grados cuál va a ser el seno de 45
grados el seno de 45 grados va a ser
igual a raíz de 2 entre 2 pueden usar
una calculadora para encontrarlo o
quizás lo recuerden el círculo unitario
el coseno de 45 grados también va a ser
la raíz cuadrada de 2 / 2
y ahora que tenemos esto podemos
sustituirlo en nuestra fórmula justo por
acá por lo que la distancia óptima a
recorrer o la distancia en función de un
ángulo de 45 grados va a ser igual a 2
por s cuadrada / g por el coseno detecta
que es raíz de 2 entre 2
por el seno de teta que también es raíz
cuadrada de 2 entre 2 simplificamos esto
raíz cuadrada de 2 x raíz cuadrada de 2
va a ser 2 este 12 cancela con este 2 de
abajo
este otro 2 que tenemos aquí abajo se
cancela con el 2 que tenemos aquí arriba
a la izquierda por lo que nos va a
quedar que la distancia óptima a 45
grados es igual a ese cuadrada entre g
suponiendo que no hay resistencia al
aire digamos que es una circunstancia
ideal pero no importa en qué planeta se
encuentren o qué tan rápido lo lancen el
mejor ángulo siempre será 45 grados
suponiendo que no hay resistencia al
aire y si hacen el lanzamiento con este
ángulo óptimo la distancia óptima será s
cuadrada / g si regresamos al problema
original y especificamos que s es igual
a 10 metros por segundo
y nuestra g es igual a 10 metros por
segundo al cuadrado
la distancia óptima la distancia óptima
sera
ese cuadrado es decir 100
entre la gravedad que es 10 y a la
elevada al cuadrado las unidades
tendremos metros cuadrados entre
segundos al cuadrado
y esto va a estar dividido entre metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado simplificamos
las unidades segundos al cuadrado se
cancelan este metro de aquí abajo se
cancela con los metros al cuadrado de
aquí arriba y nos queda que la distancia
óptima es de 10 metros estuvo bastante
interesante